welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we are taking your calls right here
on the Benjen Shapiro show so now would
be a great time for you to call in at
eight five five two three six and thirty
two twenty eight Ellen in New York
you're on the bench Pierrot Shackleford
Ellen are you doing fine longtime fan I
wanted to ask you about abortion so I
think that the left is absolutely
disgusting in the way that they
celebrate abortion like what Williams
did at the Golden Globes however because
I am I come from a medical background
I'm a dental student right now I think
that there should be a cutoff date at
which the I wish the fetus becomes a
viable fetus where if it were to be
pretty term it would be able to survive
I think that should be and it's a good
compromise between the left and the
right I just want to know your thoughts
about that it's hard to make a
compromise on the basis of viability
simply because viability is such a vague
standard first of all it's never been
completely to find what viability
constitutes so some people will say
viability outside the womb without mom's
help well what about the help of
machines what if we develop artificial
wounds what about all the people I mean
frankly a baby outside the one without
moms help will die also right I mean if
you've ever had a young child you know
that children without any care will
quickly plotz if you don't take care of
them
viability is a very difficult moral
standard to uphold also scientifically
it's difficult to uphold it also it's
difficult to explain why exactly
viability should be the standard for
whether or not a human life is valuable
or not specifically in a case when
waiting for two weeks makes the child
viable for example so the example that
I've used is there there are a lot of
elderly people who are simply not viable
right there they're on machines they are
being kept alive by those machines yeah
could you remove those people from
machines of two weeks from now they're
going to recover the answer would be no
right I mean it doesn't it doesn't make
their life worth any less the fact that
they are non viable at this point beyond
that you know as far as how this issue
should be approached the issue should be
approached in my view from Nuge
politically speaking not morally
speaking but politically speaking
pro-life people should approach this
issue by saying to democrats okay i
understand you don't agree that there
should be a ban on abortion at week one
but do you agree that there should be a
ban on abortion by week 16 how about
week 14 how about week 12 how about week
10 because the fact is that as you start
to draw
closer and closer two points of
conception you are saving more and more
lives and it's easier to find wiggle
room for folks on the left in this
without having to force them to confront
their base assumptions when you are not
starting with the argument from
conception when you start from the
argument that is that is much easier to
make like take a look at this picture of
an ultrasound that looks just like a
baby again I think viability is a weak
argument generally but you know anything
that prevents future abortions I'm in
favor of so even incremental legislation
I'd be in favor of valid thank you I
really appreciate the call Jeremy in
Fort Worth Texas you're on ben shapiro
show go for jeremy hi Ben just want to
say I'm a big fan of your politics I
think you do a great job my question a
little bit more philosophical I've seen
your discussions with people like Sam
Harris in the past you talked about
morality free will stuff like that I've
always done the really fascinating but
um always the only thing to be cut so
short I've heard you defend things like
the existence of free will by saying
like concepts like responsibilities
don't make sense unless Free Will exists
my question for you is like why do you
think this is the case why can't we be
held responsible for our actions
if freewill doesn't exist so I think the
answer Jeremy is inherent in this in the
question he just asks you said how can
we be about a held respect we be held
responsible for our actions
if freewill doesn't exist and the answer
in my view is that they're not our
actions if freewill doesn't exist like
what makes an action yours the fact that
that you were the body that that made
the action happen technically speaking
or the facts that you actually made the
decision that made the action happen so
the the sort of baruch spinoza the
philosopher the the his view of the
universe is that free will does not
exist that we are effectively stones
that have been thrown but have the
misimpression that we are moving under
under the force of our own well the
problem is that once it is society's
fault or once it is the environments
fault or once it is genetics fault
everything that you do why should you be
punished on a moral level for action now
you can make a social engineering
argument that what is best for society
is for people who have a certain
biological predisposition toward certain
criminal activity to be put in jail
that's not an a responsibility argument
that's a social shaping message but the
question of moral responsibility is why
would you be held morally responsible
for an action that is not your fault
after all
when somebody's criminally insane when
they don't know the difference between
right and wrong
we don't hold them criminally
accountable in the same way as somebody
who premeditated a murder if you are a
person who is who is pushed into another
person and that person flies in front of
a train right here you're in a train
platform somebody pushes you you knock
the guy in front of a train we're not
gonna hold you responsible for murder
the same way we would if you're the
person who push the person in front of
the Train so the question of moral
responsibility lies in your ability to
act otherwise they're a bunch of
different takes on freewill the only two
I think that make any sense are the
fully deterministic insane harris takes
and the fully freewill position which is
the position that i take even the fully
freewill position does not ignore the
impacts of environments in genetics it
says that in limited circumstances you
have the ability to choose otherwise
then there are people who articulate
what's called the compatibilist position
which is the idea that while your
actions are predetermined so long as
there is nothing that is actively
preventing you from doing a thing if you
do it you have responsibility I've never
found that completely compelling because
again do you hold animals responsible
for their own actions on a moral level
they don't have that something has to
distinguish human beings from animals
you know the traditional philosophers
say that that is the ability of human
beings to reason and use their will it's
difficult to make the argument why
humans are different from cows other
than in sort of complexity of neural
firing if you are a full determinist
Jeremy I see I see see they don't the
only reason why I ask is because I think
there is a way like so you mentioned the
compatible compatibilist notion I think
there is a like definitions of freewill
and responsibility that do sort of make
sense of this for instance if you think
of responsibility as just holding people
accountable for their actions for the
sake of changing their future behavior
then that's perfectly consistent with
you know saying well we don't have
freewill right that's right you can make
a utilitarian argument along those lines
the problem is that I'm not sure that
utilitarian arguments take you all that
far because the truth is that on utility
level if you want to hold people
accountable for their actions in a way
that prevents them from committing
future bad actions the easiest way to do
that would be to kill shoplifters right
and no one is in favor of that on a on a
practical level because obviously we
believe that human beings have an
inherent value that so that this whole
conversation about freewill is also tied
up with the idea of what
makes a human-being valuable as opposed
to an animal or as opposed to a widget
and that conversation I don't think can
be had separate Jeremy really appreciate
the phone call Pat in Houston Texas
you're on the bench beyond serrano
format hey Ben my question is why should
we draw the line for abortion that
capacity for consciousness instead of
conception so in my view very laws
oughta conserve beings with capacity for
consciousness and this constant arises
from like your limbic system and
information processing so this
information processing is heavily tied
in sensation time to the signs of
sensation are about eight twelve weeks
so watching we draw a line there and
said those conceptual well so the
question is why should capacity for
consciousness be the line right now the
burden of proof is on you to show why
capacity for consciousness should be the
line particularly because consciousness
is more of a sliding scale I mean the
fact is that unfortunately consciousness
is not binary it's not like you're
unconscious week nine and now we tend
you are a fully conscious human being
capable of recognizing your surroundings
that obviously is not true babies hold
consciousness in a different way than
older children do which is why Peter
Singer the philosopher from Princeton
has suggested that infanticide should be
okay up to year three right so the
question is what level of consciousness
do you feel is necessary in order to
preserve a human life
I think consciousness is kind of a bad
argument because as I've said before
there are times when you are temporarily
unconscious right I mean like you are
you are unconscious when you are asleep
this does not deride your value of life
and when you're talking about a baby
that is developing no more fetus or an
embryo developing in the womb you are
talking about temporary unconsciousness
because they are in the process of
development right so to push back on
that I think that human beings have a
prima facie case for developing
capacious consciousness so once this
capacity is instantiated that is the
point in which we deem them as
inherently valuable as human beings so
the question of like being unconscious
you still have the capacity for
consciousness that's what I don't kill
people that are vegetables because they
still have this neurological capacity
for consciousness which our
understanding of neurology has in little
doubt that's a time-delay question Pat
because the fact is that as the baby
develops it has the quote-unquote
capacity it depends on your definition I
don't mean to be a lawyer lawyerly here
but it depends on your definition of
capacity do you mean that right now if I
woke you up you would be you would be
fully conscious because again vegetables
you can't stab in the chest
those people have less of a possibility
very often of
into consciousness than a normal human
embryo which given you know several
weeks will in fact grow into
consciousness so I do not framework
would be the capacity I'm talking about
here so like the actual neural
sensations and the actual neural
connections these are the capacity right
the problem is again you end you do end
up in sort of a eugenic moral box here
in the sense that there are a lot of
people who are adults who have limited
capacity capacities for it for
consciousness and we presumably don't
want to kill them so if you're talking
about a general human capacity for
consciousness that would extend to
people where if you time-delay for three
weeks they do like the actual capacity
for consciousness the argument I'm
making is the capacity for consciousness
is instantiated not when the brain is
developed to the point where you are a
conscious to a certain very very
baseline level at week nine in the womb
it is instantiated at consumption
because again you will be a fully
conscious creature given the
inappropriate period of time as long as
you are not killed Pat I really
appreciate the call we'll get to more of
your calls in just one second at eight
five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight first let's talk about
something that you can do for your
family for yourself that really is
important and really is fantastic and
that is preserving your memories okay so
I know that out in your garage of a
bunch of old films from Grandma and you
haven't watched them she doesn't watch
them nobody's seen them for forty years
because who the hell has a machine
capable of playing back film reels and
projecting them on the wall these days
you need everything in a digital file
you need everything in a digital format
here's where legacy box comes in so I
just gave my parents a legacy box so
they can put all of their old film reels
in there send it off to legacy box have
all the labels shipped with them right
so they can keep track of all their
materials legacy box then takes all
those materials puts it on a on a thumb
drive puts it in a DVD or a convenient
digital download and then sends you back
all your original material so now it's
all accessible and it's easy to get you
and you can watch it it is fantastic go
check out legacy box right now I know
the people who founded legacy box not
only are they trustworthy they are
really entrepreneurial helping out their
company I think is a great thing to do
and obviously the product is greater I
wouldn't be talking about it it started
preserving your past today go to legacy
box comm slash radio to get 40% off your
first order right now save your time and
your memories go to legacy box comm
slash radio and save 40% again legacy
box comm slash radio and get 40% off
your first order we're taking your calls
at eight five five two three
6:32 28 Keith in La Crescenta you're on
the bench Shapiro she'll go for Keith I
been longtime fan of the show keep doing
God's work man I appreciate it thank you
as one of the only other White Sox fans
in LA and since today's Hosea Braves
birthday and by the way somebody else's
birthday's tomorrow as well I just want
to ask you who do you think is the best
prospect in their system and how
optimistic are you about the team's
future thanks so I'm very optimistic
about the White Sox future I know this
is a very sectional question very few
people care about the White Sox but I do
so deal with it okay so the White Sox
future is great they have a fantastic
group of prospects that are coming up
Michael kopeck is coming back from Tommy
John surgery got loose robe a robe Aaron
centerfield at some point Nick Madrigal
who's their second baseman will come up
they just signed a bunch of free agents
including Dallas cuoco as well as Gio
Gonzalez the Sox are gonna be
competitive this year they'll compete
for the AL Wild Card if not for the
Central Division title itself and the
next few years look really good they
have a very young very talented team
thanks for the White Sox question always
puts me in a good mood at least when
they don't stink Zack unions yeah you're
on the bench bureau she'll go for exact
say that I agree with you on most things
that you say but whenever I bring up
your arguments on racism or light
privilege to friends of opposing views
they say what you say is both and that
you speak up you can't speak on the
subject because you're not black and
don't understand their daily struggles
in society and that you blatantly ignore
obvious cases or racially motivated acts
against black people like with kalief
Browder or Trayvon Martin so what would
your response be to that so you have to
take each individual circumstance under
the conditions in which it was committed
so I will admit that I don't know the
first name that you refer to there so I
will have to look up that case the
Trayvon Martin case is a particular case
where the Justice Department under
Barack Obama found there was no racial
motivation to that particular killing I
mean that the entire killing was
dismissed by a jury because the the case
was that Trayvon Martin at the time of
the shooting was sitting atop George
Zimmerman and banging his head into the
ground according to witness testimony
and forensic evidence so that is not a
great case of racism if you wanna talk
about a great case of racism then you
would talk about the case of Walter
Scott up in South Carolina which I have
talked about extensively right a case
where a cop shot a black man in the back
and then planted a gun on him that guy
went to jail for life he should have
gone to jail for life when there
the actual racism I like we're all on
the same side here
my general statement is that there is no
such thing as quote-unquote
institutional racism that institutions
are not racist that if you are if you're
looking at individuals who are being
racist or if you can spot an institution
that is acting in a racist fashion we
will all be on the same side where I
don't like is the generalized argument
that America is institutionally racist
or systemically racist when your only
evidence of quote-unquote institutional
or systemic racism is that there is
disproportionate impact of a law on a
particular population without looking
into the actual activities within
population so for example when people
say the criminal justice system is
racist because a disproportionate number
of black people are in jail that does
not take into account differential crime
rates among populations right if you can
show me that it's just proportionate
number of black people as compared to
crime rates are in jail
then we can talk about where the racism
lies in the system but if you are just
saying that a disproportionate number of
black people are in jail for homicide
when unfortunately a disproportionate
number of homicides are committed by
black people that is not evidence of
systemic racism inside the system so in
other words we should all be looking at
instances of racism to fight when people
blame all in a all in inequality on
inequity when they blame all
disproportion on some sort of vague
racism that they can't define that
you're sort of spit out a phrase like
white privilege or institutional racism
without explaining exactly what in the
policy is racist or who are the racists
we implemented the policy I've said
before I think that's ghost hunting and
I think that that is not designed to
actually come up with a solution I think
it's actually designed to forestall a
solution that we can all agree on
because again if you show me a racist
incident then I'm happy to not only
label it racist but say that the person
should be punished to the full extent of
the law Zack thank you well I really
appreciate the call okay we'll take more
of your calls at eight five five two
three six 32:28 coming up you're
listening to the Ben Shapiro show
[Applause]
[Music]
you